aujourd'hui je vous raconter les débuts
de nos grands chanteurs alors on va
commencer avec le plus grand la toute
première apparition télé de charles
aznavour charles aznavour c'était en
1955 dans l'émission télé paris ils
chantent les palais de nos chimères
c'est pour toi benhaim regarder la
première télé de charles aznavour
après j'ai du jour 1 g du céline dion
j'ai du club françoise du johnny j'ai dû
mylène farmer regardez j'ai dû
[Applaudissements]
la jauge est de 10 5 ans alors ce que je
pense depuis longtemps et puis très
lente
nous le sommes mariés par un jour de
printemps sans prêtre us en mairie sans
amis ni parlant nous n'avions tout au
plus des mois que 20 ans mais un désir
d'adultes brûler nos coeurs d'enfants
l'amour ennuyer mansi pas nos coeurs
nous étions sans lacets du monde au
bonheur dans les yeux agrandis nous
passer nulle peur car la jeunesse e ri
quand l'enfant se meurt et l'acharnement
il n'y avait plus de 30 ans parce que
charles aznavour il n'a pas chanté tout
de suite il a commencé par écrire pour
les autres pour edith piaf notamment
avant de vraiment se lancer charles
aznavour qui j'ai eu le voilà vraiment
là l'honneur de connaître
voilà que voilà que j'admirais beaucoup
qui était exceptionnel l'autre
gigantesque que c'est bien sûr john
dalli descend en 1961 il se retrouve
dans une émission assez chic en suisse
ce sera sa première télévision là bas et
on voit qu'il est déjà bien entraîné aux
yeux de jean au jeu de jambes
regardez johnny sa première télé 61 sa
première télé regarde il s'agit de
johnny hallyday
[Musique]
cela s'appelait du gouver long de nos
chemins en avions entendu le précieux
c'est un peu du poitou quatre ans
[Musique]
ça c'était la première télé de johnny
ouais ça y avait un look un gars bien
quelque chose il y avait il y avait 1
d'evian en 1962 claude lelouch offre sa
toute première télé un petit jeune
fraîchement débarquée d'egypte qui
ramenait un peu c'est claude françois et
claude lelouch pu réaliser un clip
belles belles belles ça va tourner en
boucle toute la journée comme si là des
piques et le jeu de jambes à johnny
hallyday regarder pour que ça marche
lui aussi mais c'est un truc de ouf is
on avait c'était là le délire à l'époque
regarder les filles tu sais méfie toi
c'est parce que tu crois sont toutes
[Musique]
ali
fou de joie ou de nous laver trois mois
plus tôt
un jour et puis déduire de plus
tu vas rencontrer peut-être
soir double hirabe rentrer plus tôt on
verra si tu en auras et plus d'une
comprendra dans ces moments tu te
souviendras peut-on vieux père disait
elles sont toutes mes bébés le jour
ouais c'est vrai il y avait il ya vingt
qu'il y avait quelque chose à paris le
buste très très rigide en est que le
bail d'origine c'est juste moi j'ai le
bac pas tuer l'origine ce soir
exactement merci rené c'est important
d'avoir une personne comme toi pour nous
dire c'est à 17 ans rené malleville bien
sûr de danse avec les stars
allez on va revenir en 80 c'est la toute
première apparition de celle qui
enflamme aujourd'hui las vegas c'est
céline dion alors c'est la qualité télé
de l'époque je vous le dis mais la
puissance de voix de céline dion est
déjà incroyable regardez première
apparition au québec de céline dion elle
avait 13 ans et sa première telle date
[Musique]
en gt
m
[Musique]
partez
ouais est la voie la mort y est j'ai
mangé dans la gueule non mais c'est bien
ça fait du bien elle poussait à présent
ces lignes ont 13 ans retournez voir la
première télé de mylène farmer
ah oui c'est fait en 84 voilà elles sont
emma mois sur fond de trois pires idées
mylène farmer regarde dans l'adolescence
d'un très bon souvenir ou non très
mauvais très mauvais et puis tout lancé
christophe des crasses touristes ont
carrément c'est s'effrayant
[Musique]
maman à temps
beau l'amour prend infirmières burqa
les mois
[Musique]
nous
ce
elle avait quelque chose mais les
bleuets les murs ali mais maintenant
elle à elle avait un truc mais les mieux
maintenant tu es toujours l'univers mais
bah oui oui oui jean messi rémois ya
quelque chose qui m'étonne c'est
honnêtement chaque fois vous nous sortez
des perles comme ça de la télé les camps
des bulles écoute moi j'ai l'impression
d'avoir jamais vu ces images
alors peut-être que je me trompe mais
pourtant je regarde beaucoup la télé ou
alors est ce que vous avez fait des
découvertes
merci c'est une interview après des
missions pour un trajet du travail
j'adore ce mec
les séries on voulait rendre hommage à
quelqu'un qui nous manque beaucoup
puisque c'est grégory lemarchal
on croit à tort que sa première télé
c'est la star academy mais non grégory
lemarchal apparaît pour la première fois
à la télévision en 99 chez laurent boyer
dans graines de star sur m6 regardez y
la saison et balavoine et déjà son
chanteur préféré regarder la chanson sa
face avant tout ça pense même avant
l'école c'est tellement forces et j'ai
envie de vivre de ça si jamais j'arrive
à faire avec va faire une carrière je
serai
j'ose très humble je crois qu'il y
aurait vis ma vie autrement dès 13 ans
norman la présente je m'appelle
si on m'avait
[Musique]
gagner de l'argent
et c'est tout
[Musique]
il faudrait
pourquoi
que faire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous savez que c'est un
triste anniversaire puisque ça fait 13
ans tout pile que grégory lemarchal nous
a quittés voilà on attend avec
impatience la série 1
voilà qui va être faite sur tf1
concernant sa ville